[Music]
you're gonna act how long have you been
acting you got started as a kid right
yeah I was young I was young but you
didn't you you weren't from an acting
family whatever were there any other
people acting in your family I mean they
act a fool like just act a fool they
don't really write write I then I come
from an acting family yeah we are I mean
we all act yeah yeah yeah but I mean you
know I was I was pushing forward as an
actor I'm very young a lot of
disappointment yeah well what was the
kind of roles that you wanted when you
were a kid what was like your dream role
I wanted to be the black Ranger
I'm not joking which range I don't know
which range of the black line what range
I mean Power Ranger Ranger Power Ranger
all right he's gonna say there's no
black Lone Ranger no there should have
been that was it no maybe at the Power
Rangers yeah it was coming out this new
show the breakdown came out I had all
the skill sets could do martial arts
could dance right don't get the part so
you know I'm like I'm ready to judge
break this guy down run home with my
Jam's war backpack I turn it on 3:30 and
I start studying I was like look at my
brother I was like is this kind of
missing a finger the guy who got it he's
missing it was bit I'm like no is this
guy missing a finger look I brought I
brought yeah you guys don't believe you
brought this I haven't seen this I'm
dead serious
Wow that's the guy who got the part yes
okay so the guy who got the part was
missing a finger he was missing a finger
and I was just all stricken because you
know we wanted to see if they were
really doing the stunts because when
they did that there was no finger with
the thing but when he had the gloves
when he had read all the fingers I was
like they're not doing their own stunts
I knew that right then and
Wow wait a minute I'm serious because it
was weird they I didn't think they had
it in the budget to like do a four
finger glove cuz otherwise it'll just be
like hanging it would have been weird so
anyway I was out you were busting on
this guy cuz he was missing one finger
listen Shonda Rhimes Shonda Rhimes said
you know Kerry Washington's father on
the show said you have to be 10 times
better to get half so much he was nine
times better oh my oh my god so go guys
take out you know yourself know 9 times
better is ok no no that guy sounds like
he did the role just fine and it doesn't
seem like anybody knows he was masterful
at it he's a great exact please don't as
a matter of fact oh he's gonna love that
I ran I I saw this guy I saw this guy as
an adult like probably last year and he
saw the dances he's an incredible salsa
dance I come into this place and I'll
flood I'd eat those and he was austere
than tearing up the floor and you know
in salsa you got a lead with the finger
so he likes fun this girl she was
spinning like all around and then he
went to spin her again with this finger
and she slipped through the finger into
the ice it's not true
like she slipped through my fingers he's
like no she slipped through your finger
you are obsessed I was obsessed with the
missing finger well I I think you got to
talk to this guy you guys got to get
this clock Holmes was on the case I was
like mm-hmm that's not the guy okay
let's move on we have to because I'm
gonna get assaulted by people with
missing fingers yes I think so
I think Hey look just to show you my
finger is messed up it's like a house
like it's broken so I have I have how do
we know you're not just bending you look
at me I'm missing a hand
[Applause]
that's hilarious all right well you got
a lot of mail to answer oh my god